Okay.
Okay,
so the very last assignment,
please go to this unofficial
lux renders seen repository.
There's also a link below it that shows
you how the individual scenes looked
like.
Please choose a scene and render it with
an unbiased method several times and
merge the results together.
I hope that you remember from the previous
lecture how you can merge together
individual runs of unbiased algorithms
and hopefully get something better than
the individual images.
Do it with other algorithms,
both biased and unbiased algorithms.
I've also uploaded a settings file to
help you with these different algorithms
and see what happens.
I don't want to spoil the fun Pat.
Obviously we expect a given class of
algorithms to perform well in this regard
and some of them not so much.
Also tried to experiment with
photo mapping type Algorithms.
Place your observations in
the observations dot txt file.
Tell me what kind of
algorithm worked where,
what are the failure cases and why and
is this what you have expected or did you
get something different?
Remember when we were doing
mathematics in the very first lectures,
we first always listed our expectations
and then after we got the results we
discussed whether reality was in
line with our expectations or not.
This is a really good methodologies,
so please do it all the time.
There will be a rendering competition
afterwards where a really prestigious
international committee will judge your
work and there are lots of valuable
prizes.
We will get three tickets to the next
year's see EGC conference and peak sal
Vienna. So that's a total of six
free conference tickets for you.
I'm also holding a talk at the CJC so I
would be more than excited to meet you
there.
So the CGC is the central
European Games conference.
This is big Selfie Cellfina.
Their flier from last year.
So after you handed in your work, you
may be getting one of the three prizes.
The third prize is plus half of a grade
on the exam and this provided that you
would already pass the course.
The second prize is plus
one grade on the exam.
And the first prize is perhaps
this is the official description,
perhaps an even greater
influence on the exam grade.
If you don't really have artistic veins
or you would like to do some programming
assignment instead of deluxe renders
seem contest, you're free to do that.
Please contact me.
Let's cook up a realistic and exciting
problem for you that you can solve.
So don't just start pounding away at
your keyboard and doing something.
Please write to me so we can discuss
what you're exactly going to do.
And if you do that, you are going to be
subject to the very same price. Okay,
so what about the rendering contest?
A contest theme this year
is going to be fluids.
It's great because we have
a great fluid simulator in,
you have to create a scene and
handling converged images, not noisy,
converged images of the scene.
Okay,
so what is the list of things
that you need to hand in?
We would like to get the Lux renders
scene. Please copy every asset,
every texture, every Mesh, everything
that you have in the scene.
In this Lux render seen directory
that you give to us so we can run it
ourselves. We need also, like I said,
a completely noise free rendered image.
We would also need the blend file or
if you're using a different model or
program you are absolutely free
to use that. Please be my guest.
Just please send us the project file and
also send us one text file with a few
lines on what you try to accomplish
and why you think that your work is the
greatest work ever created by humanity.
Third Party sources for mashes are
fine but you have to give credit to the
people who created it.
Important.
We also ask for a halfway progress report.
What does it mean?
There will be a final deadline for the
assignment and halfway through death
there will be another deadline where I
expect you to send me an email with the
very same subject as
the assignment itself.
You send me one rendered
image which is just a rough,
really rough draft of
what you are going to do.
So I'd like to see your current progress
and at least one line of text with your
plans.
What are you exactly trying to accomplish
this we do because we would like to
discourage people from trying to put
together some seen in the last two days of
the assignment and not have enough time
to render it correctly or to develop it
correctly.
You would just like to make sure that
you are on time and please check the
course website to see what exactly
are the deadlines for this. Okay,
so who will be on the committee?
First, John Phillip Commodity.
He is the head developer of flex render,
the kindest,
kindest person who has been on this
committee for the third year now and he's
always very excited to
see your work Voita chaos.
You hopefully remember
the name from before.
He's the head of the rendering group
of these new research Surrey and an
excellent,
a truly excellent researcher.
[inaudible] our beloved professor who is
the head of the rendering group at our
university.
What about the programming guys?
If you don't want to participate in
the rendering contest, that's fine.
That's perfectly fine. There's two
different things that you can do. One,
do something with lux render.
We have, for instance,
a bank tracker where people are asking
for features and people are also asking
for bucks to be fixed.
So if you're interested in this,
then please take a look and if you
come it something that is useful,
then you will be subject to a first prize.
Now note that the first price
can be won by multiple people.
If you cross a given threshold
with the quality of your work,
then you will be subjected to the first
prize and there may be many of you who
do and also the small paint line where
you can improve small pain by practically
anything you can add by
direction of the past.
Tracing multiple important
sampling, fought on mapping,
whatever you have in mind,
but before you decide on anything,
contact me.
Last year's theme was volumetric caustics.
I think that's an amazing theme,
but this year this is not what
we are going to be interested in.
What we are going to be interested
in is fluid simulations.
This scene was created in blender.
So you can do sophisticated simulations
like this and even much more
sophisticated than this.
I have prepared some blander fluid
simulation tutorials for you.
So please take a look
and please make sure that your simulation
is the very least 300 cube and also an
example video to set the tone.
This is taken from the real
flow reel from last year.
It is absolutely amazing.
Make sure to take a look and the subject
of the email that we're looking for is
the very same. You only need to
increment a number of the assignment
and that's it.
It's been a wonderful journey for me.
So thanks for tuning in.
I was trying my very best to teach you
the intricacies of light transport and I
hope that now you indeed
see the world differently.
I got some student feedbacks from many
of you and I got the kindest of words,
so thank you very much.
I'm really grateful and if you're
watching this through the Internet,
then we have a comment section.
Let us know if you like the course.
So thank you very much.
And despite the fact that it
seems that the course ends here,
we have a lecturer from before
that we haven't published yet.
There'll be some more videos with
Hamas who teaches you how to compute
subsurface scattering. So one
more time. Thank you very much,
and it's been a wonderful journey.
Thanks. I'll see you later.